[Musik]
das waren drei drehungen auf ein
weihnachtsfest läuft was geht hertz
willkommen war nur ein video
ja ja die schon lesen aussieht was hat
alex wie davor also ich hoffe dass sie
dort gut und ich kann doch wirklich
durchziehen und denken wenig dabei alter
dann fick deinen körper total unwichtig
gesorgt sondern videos das zerstört sein
körper total würde ich sagen auf jeden
fall habe ich mir gedacht er alex du
machst du witze und ich habe auf youtube
irgendwie so eine dokumentation über so
ein typ gesehen der so spielt sich
gleich mehreren jahren nur von pizza
ernährt und ich hab mir gedacht ehrlich
das kannste auch aber du machst es nicht
mehrere jahre sondern eine woche ganz
ehrlich ich finde das auch so lange eine
woche darf ich wirklich 0% oder wir es
einfach mal nur pizza stores neulich
klinik gehört nicht okay dabei auf
deiner ja das früheste wird bei uns
immer sachen beginnt morgens meistens
zum studium oder wenn ich lange es oft
ganz lange ihres länger also frühstücken
tue ich mich so auf
deswegen gibt mittags und abends immer
pizza das müsste langen insgesamt müssen
das so um die 14 wissen sein
ich will eins gar nicht lange lagern ich
muss sofort mal eine pizza lieferdienst
unbestellt die erste pizza für heute das
ist schon irgendwie ein cooles gefühl
jetzt einfach jeden tag gutes essen zu
haben arbeitskanal ausweisen würde gern
mal gestellt und zwar eine salami
schinken
mai genau und eine margarita happy size
also ich kann mich jetzt darauf
einstellen
so entspricht werde ich in der nächsten
woche 14 mal für die zuerst nur bestehen
wenn erst die typen sind ihr könnt ihr
bei uns in die kommentare schreiben
schaffe ich das zieht das durch was
erwartet ihr von mir wie es ablaufen und
lass nach oben da jetzt 70 stunden
später so heute man muss sagen das
wetter es wird echt gut warum auch immer
es ist schön warm 1000 auf jeden fall
ist die pizza.de sondern dass hier und
haben jetzt mal ganz sondern mit
margarita ich esse eigentlich am
liebsten margarita aber da ist ja in
zukunft erst mal 14 pizzen essen muss
wahrscheinlich während auch mehr wenn
man hunger hat bestellen was ich halt
noch eine
ich habe dann ja sozusagen auch mal ein
bisschen zeit und auszuprobieren was mir
dennoch so schmeckt ja jetzt wird erst
mal gegessen
so leute ich muss sagen jetzt ist der
erste das ich habe irgendwie vergessen
aufzunehmen aber morgen geht es weiter
bestellt wird er denkt geradezu herbert
der sie machen experiment ist jetzt
einfach nur tief ab heute mittag macht
das mal kurz so auf jeden fall
ich habe mir überlegt ich mache das
ganze auch ein bisschen seine loks
dating wertlos ich muss ein bisschen
sony ja wer mit zwölf uhr mittags und
jetzt muss ich mir erst mal eine pizza
und das gleich also das wetter ist auf
jeden fall krass was formal sagen wenn
übrigens gehabt dass ich öfter ich hab
dann megawatt könnte ja mal schauen wir
jetzt noch nach oben da lassen dann sehe
ich das weil da habe ich mega bock drauf
auf die schliche gekommen
leute eins kann ich mir sagen wird
niemals zu diesem backwerk und holt euch
besitzer wenn ihr das schon drei stunden
liegt die uni war es kein bisschen dazu
gemacht ich wollte auch ein bisschen
blog artig deswegen ich habe hier von
146 dank an dieser stelle ist ein echt
cooler job ist meine videobefragung von
ihm erstmal diese karten zu bekommen
dankeschön erwartet aber diese schule
eigentlich am meisten die meist auch
ganz cool von ani las ich weiß nicht wie
die heißen einfach geil aus und das
highlight ist einfach ich schäme mich
schon etwas dazu sagen aber ich habe mir
gedacht ich müsste mal von diesem
philipp plein und das habe ich jetzt
auch im gesang an der stelle nachdem man
die nächste petri angerufen wird
und wir sehen uns später leute wir
arbeiten abend ich hab mir gerade meine
pizza geholt ich wollte so schnell neben
abdrehen und zwar für gedacht er heute
nebenbei das übrigens fußball so wundert
euch nicht ich hab ihm gesagt nach dabei
aber mit bisschen weniger schicken und
ananas und wie man sieht
[Musik]
sieht auf jeden fall recht gut aus dass
ich mir ordentlich rein guckt ein
bisschen fußball sondern ist das glaube
ich schon meine vierte pizza oder so ich
werde es auch nicht jeder auf leben das
müsse überhaupt sein weil dann wird das
video glaube ich zehn jahre lang gehen
aber morgen jetzt ab zum kollegen von
mir damals ja schon wie ich das machen
danach gibt's nach hause dann gibts auch
frankfurt und irgendwie muss sich ja die
ganze zeit also wird auf jeden fall
interessant ich werde mich auf jeden
fall geht es weiter mit dem zug nach
münster und leckere pizza hut bis gleich
daniel volk sagen
[Musik]
halle b2 und einmal margarita uns allein
mit diesem an
[Musik]
als letztes mittel sein
wir sehen uns vom ersten übertragen
ich bin jetzt hier in münster
wir können ja mal sagen wenn ihr unsere
und raps man die kommentare auf jeden
fall spielen hat und ja ich muss
natürlich mein plan weiter fortsetzen
wird heute abend treten
ein krokodil
leider vorher welche blitz hat auf jeden
fall cool also da kann man auf jeden
fall mal hingehen merkt man hat nicht so
geschmeckt aber mittlerweile feier statt
mal sehen was mit abend ich hoffe ganz
schnell noch ein kurzes update machen
weil viele sicher bestimmt natürlich
fragen geht die pizza nicht leisten sagt
es muss um ehrlich zu sein sagen so
natürlich zum beispiel gestern abend
hätte ich vieles andere vergessen aber
gerade freue ich mich auf die spitze
aber es sind noch ein paar tage und ich
denke die freude wird mir noch vergehen
vorgesehen dass ich drei leute
wir haben jetzt gerade abend und zwar
wird jetzt natürlich was machen wir
genau leute und zwar wir sind sie gerade
weil domino's pizza unterstellen für
mich und das hätte man sicher und
verlegte die analysen weisen kein kupon
gibt kriegen den ice dazu anhalte mit
121 gesagt ich es nur pizza aber keine
zeit mehr drin
also wir sehen uns gleich drei leute auf
meiner peter sind einfach tomaten
ich war keine tomaten wir haben jetzt
zwar schon 16 uhr 15 waren gestern etwas
länger unterwegs deswegen wenn wir
erfolgreich und aufgestanden und jetzt
geht es natürlich werde es anders geht
wegen ihr zugesagt
die gefühlte zwei dieser woche oder spaß
hat überhaupt kein faktor
ich fühle mich schlecht ich würde am
liebsten verbringt gesundes etwas wie
viel besser schmeckt aber egal es gibt
jetzt eine pizza nur leute dass die
kleinsten service jetzt was ich mich
frage impfen lassen also konnte
auf jeden fall war
so leute pfizer ging klar aber ich habe
absolut kein bock mehr drauf
morgen ist endlich vorbei so leute also
ich war jetzt gerade mit dem krieg nach
hause ich weiß zwei wochen wieder nach
hause fährt momentan nach hause und
wagenräder frankfurt heute haben wir sie
natürlich noch die eine oder andere
bittere eingezogen als ich jetzt sagen
wir sind heute abend weiter abend könnte
ich eigentlich mal wieder irgendwas
anderes herzen so klar ausgefallen
mal gucken 128 nacht hat er mittlerweile
schon 223 mein schlaf erst wieder hin
sind aussagen waren gelaufen auf jeden
fall ist es ein kleines problem
den haben wir nicht mehr auf deswegen
muss sich jetzt zur tankstelle und viel
besser kaufen
let's go
[Musik]
das erste stück habe ich schon vergessen
dass zweiten morgen so jetzt wird
erstmal natürlich bezeichnen
danach geht's ab nach essen und von
essen nach frankfurt das problem ist
gerade die meisten pizzerien haben wir
irgendwie zu warum auch immer
aber mir macht mein glück schaut nämlich
ohne spaß noch gar nichts gegessen und
ich habe extrem hunger nur auf pizza
aber egal nur noch weiter dann habe ich
eigentlich geschafft dass ich aber schon
mal sagen kann man fühlt sich dadurch
irgendwie hässlich ich fühle mich total
normal ernährt und überhaupt nicht
schlecht also an sich ich weiß nicht was
dagegen spricht nur pizza zu essen
manchmal riecht auch wenn man bock hat
auch was anderes aber ungesund empfinde
ich das jetzt nicht auch wenn sicher
natürlich zu an leute witznummer weiß
nicht 13
so ist auch am start eigentlich ist die
salami aber die schwarzen runter auf
jeden fall gut holz schönes wetter
draußen auf jeden fall gibt es
vielleicht bloß nach essen und danach
frankfurt und ich glaube mit der
nächsten pizza ist das ganze auch beende
ich habe sehr eng sagt ist auf jeden
fall schuldig so karner machen schmeckt
immer gut auch wenn man manchmal echt
keinen bock mehr auf pizza hat aber
keine ahnung ich fühle mich total gut
ernährt gar nicht unsere so also pizza
bis irgendwie jeder denke aber dass es
fast food oder so ist es auch eigentlich
aber gute fast so leute auftreten
solcher plan
leute ich bin jetzt hier bei bm mag das
ding ist eigentlich ist heute mein
letzter pitzer tag oder meine zu abend
ob ich heute am ende 40 siege weiß ich
nicht mal sehen vielleicht habe ich
glück
wir schauen jetzt mal was so geht das
wieder versorgen
wir schauen wir vielleicht kriegen eine
pizza dann melde ich mich ansonsten habe
ich gehabt aber das ist schade so naja
mal sehen ich habe im sommer so leute
ich bin jetzt die auch wegen dem
rastplatz ich muss jetzt einfach aus
essen ist einfach nur das ding jetzt die
gibt's nur trocken burger king aber
scheiß drauf spricht das jetzt ab und
die frau was bereits der breite und
sitzt am flügel werden das reicht
[Musik]
so leute freunde hat wir voll rein führt
sogar automatisch davon bei dir im auto
ist hier ist guten morgen ich bin grad
ist aufgestanden das video sollte
eigentlich nur 14 online kommen jetzt
kurz abschließendes resümee ich war
gestern noch offen
geburtstag war auf jeden fall mega cool
ich wollte euch nur auf schnell sagen
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn ihr
meint viel fast food essen zu müssen
dann ist einfach nur bitter
vollkommen okay zumindest eine woche
lang also mich körperlich gar nicht
beeinträchtigt war übels stelle ich in
meine pizza zu essen manchmal natürlich
keinen bock drauf aber ich habe es
durchgezogen
ich habe das ein bisschen unterhalten
ich weiß auch nicht wie ich ihn brauchte
ideen komme wenn ihr mehr davon was man
doch nach oben da und wird in münster
übermorgen wieder
jak dapd dienst ab er wollte nicht sagen
haut rein